(gentle music)
- [Voiceover] What if
you could speak your mind
without fear of judgment?
We brought together seven strangers,
protected their identities,
and created a space for them
to be completely honest.
What will be revealed when
they take the mask off?
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] There is something
wrong with LGBT people.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs chiming)
- [Kabal] I'm gonna say a strong no.
Yes I believe that homosexuality is a sin,
but saying that like LGBTQ+ people,
there's something wrong
with them as people,
as human beings,
that's a harsh statement. (laughs)
So it's a hard topic.
- [Dmitri] This is a
really sensitive topic
because I know that a lot of LGBTQ people
have been hurt by the church,
they've been hurt by Christians.
I personally have family
members who identify as they
who are homosexual.
While God hates sin, He loves the people,
and He loves the homosexual,
and He loves the transgender
because He died for them.
But the problem that I
do see with LGBTQ people
is that the lifestyle,
it does take away a lot of things.
They're depressed, they're
lonely all the time
and that's not the life
that God called for you.
When you receive Christ,
the spirit of God can deliver
you from homosexuality
and I've seen it happen.
The people who identify
as bisexual or homosexual
and God delivers them
and they no longer choose
to identify that way.
- [David] One thing, the Lord says that
if you have sinned against one law,
you have broken all the laws.
And so every single human being is wrong.
Like if you ask that question,
are homosexuals wrong?
Well sure.
But are they a different type of wrong?
No, they're not a different type of wrong.
They are the same wrong as I am.
- [Penny] I feel like we tend to magnify
the LGBTQ community.
For example, I come from
a Hispanic household
and sexual abuse is brushed
under the rug so many times,
straight,
but you choose to magnify,
let's say my gay cousin
over my molester uncle.
You know what I mean?
- Facts, yup.
- There's something wrong with both
- [Calvin] And the question is then
why do we magnify the
sin of homosexuality?
It's because no one goes around
saying murdering is okay,
that theft is okay,
but there are people going around saying,
well, love is love and
homosexuality is just love
and they're trying to justify it.
And so the church has to
do some sort of defense
and that's why this sin gets
more attention than the others.
And so they can escape their shame,
not by marching down a
street shouting pride,
embrace who you are, look within,
they can escape their shame
by casting it on Christ
and receiving His forgiveness.
- [Penny] Yes, amen.
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] Women who get
abortions are murderers.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs vibrating)
- [Rillian] It is God who
gives and takes away life.
Man or woman has no place taking a life
that they didn't breathe into.
There is no going around that
one I think for Christians.
You kill a baby, that
makes you a murderer.
- [Kabal] This topic,
sorry, gets me emotional because (sighs)
I've seen people go through
that and (sighs) sorry.
And they feel it in their
soul and in their spirit
that it was wrong.
And they deal with that pain
and that shame and regret.
My husband himself, him and his sisters
they are all a product of (beep)
And I mean, that's my husband. (chuckles)
So to imagine that,
like, he wouldn't be here
if his mother didn't decide
to keep them and raise them.
It's sad to think about.
- [Cashqu] Maybe it was
not in a good experience,
maybe you were (beep),
maybe you were victim
to something abusive,
maybe it wasn't planned,
but let me tell you something.
God, He's never early, never late.
He's always on time.
And the fact that you were
given this gift of life,
and if you can't handle it
or you can't take care of it,
there are options.
- [Director] Well, I'm
just wondering then.
What would you think of people
who, like, stand outside
of, like, abortion places
and try to stop people?
(Kabal chuckling)
- [Kabal] It makes me so upset,
like the people who just protest
and try to shove and
judge and condemn others.
That is not love.
That is not God.
That is not how He would handle people.
Jesus is very gentle
and He would not make them feel like
they cannot come to the Father
because they are in shame
or not worthy.
- [Calvin] I do wanna address,
I think there's a misunderstanding
about what people do
who stand out in front
of abortion clinics.
What they're doing is not abusing them,
they're not attacking them,
they're letting them know
that there's options,
telling them about
crisis pregnancy centers,
offering to adopt their children,
explaining to them what
an abortion really is.
They're doing really important work.
And if we all believe
that abortion is murder
and we all just said that we do,
well, then what it is is mass murder,
it's genocide in the United States.
It's worse than the Holocaust.
And so I wouldn't wanna
throw stones at someone
who's out in front of
the concentration camp
saying don't murder Jews.
I would wanna go alongside that person
and applaud that person
for being courageous.
And I think that's really important work
that all Christians should support
to help try to fight
abortion in this country.
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] I have had
sex outside of marriage.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs chiming)
- [Penny] Oh my God.
- Sorry.
- I'm so sorry.
Okay, I'm the right light now.
- [Kabal] Everyone was doing it.
We're on many cycles with that of like,
I've had an orgy with females, I've had...
You know that one person
you can just hit up anytime you want to
and they're available. (laughs)
At some point you have
to stop avoiding a sin
'cause God hates, not sinners but the sin
because it comes to
steal, kill, and destroy.
I'm now married and my husband
abstained till marriage
and he has had to deal with
the repercussions of my sin
in the past.
- [Dmitri] Yeah, I wasn't
saved until I was 20,
and before that time I did
have sex outside of marriage.
And even when I was
first becoming Christian
I would hear people say,
Oh you can't have sex outside of marriage.
And I said, Okay, well,
I'll do everything else,
but I won't do that one thing
because that's a really
hard thing to give up.
- [Penny] Do you know when
you have sex with somebody
it's really hard to move on from that.
You start feeling all types
of things with yourself
and it's just remembering
that God doesn't say this to be mean,
or to be a dictator, but to protect you.
- [Cashqu] Yeah, if I can add to that.
To be completely honest
with you, I'm scared of sex.
I had a very traumatic
experience when I was younger
where I've had family members
intend to take advantage of me.
And because of that traumatic experience,
I just have had that fear
to be enclosed with
just one man in a room.
- [David] Even though I
have not lost my virginity,
pornography has been something
that has been rampant to my life.
And that sexual sin as well
is truly in my spiritual
experience has been almost equal.
Going wrong against God,
going wrong against self,
that brings so much shame, so much guilt,
but when the forgiveness comes,
we see the true glory of God
because we see how broken we were
and how reformed we are through Christ.
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] Anyone who isn't
Christian is going to hell.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs vibrating)
- [Calvin] Yeah for me, this
one's a pretty easy one.
John 14:6, "I'm the way,
the truth and the life.
No one comes to the
Father except through me."
If we're Christians and we
say we believe in the Bible,
either we believe what
Jesus said or we don't.
- [David] Yeah, it's a
tough sentence to answer,
and to be honest,
I suppose I can't just
flatly say yes or no.
So it's tough,
but with that being said, what
does Christian really mean?
- [Penny] Yeah, I agree with that.
Well, I said no
because everybody uses the
word Christian now, right?
I believe there's Christians
who aren't gonna gonna go to heaven.
- [Director] What about people
who subscribe to like say,
Judaism or Islam?
- [Penny] It goes back to the Bible.
It says that to go to heaven
you have to confess with your mouth
and believe in your heart
that Jesus Christ is Lord.
And there's a lot of people who
don't identify as Christians
who believe that.
What if there's a
satanist on his deathbed,
at that moment they
confess with their mouth
and they believe in their heart.
Like they didn't live their
whole lives being Christian.
Are they gonna go to hell?
I don't believe that.
So I think to say that
if you're not Christian
you're gonna go to hell,
it's kind of an absolute
that drives more people
away from Christianity
than brings them in.
- [Kabal] I'm thinking
of babies that have died
and I don't think that
they would go to hell
because they didn't even
know how to make a sound.
(Kabal chuckles)
- [Dmitri] God gives us a choice
whether we wanna spend eternity with Him
or whether we don't,
and that's a free willed choice
that He gives to all of us.
We all have to accept
that we all are sinners
and the wages of sin is death.
The wages of sin is separation from God.
But I've heard people's stories
who didn't even know the Bible
and had near death experiences
where they actually went and visited hell.
The way that it was
described in the Bible.
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] I'm scared of dying.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs chiming)
- [David] "To live is
Christ, and to die is gain."
That's my father's favorite verse.
We are gaining eternal life,
we are gaining a new faith,
we are gaining a new body,
we are gaining everything.
Not that being here doesn't have its joys,
but to be with Him obviously
is- [Penny] It's the best.
Yeah.
I always say, I can't wait to die.
My mom hates it.
I always say, it's like, God take me now.
I'm not suicidal.
We're always saying
- No, but I get what you mean.
I get what you mean literally.
- No, my sister and I,
yeah, we're always like,
God, just come take us.
Like we don't wanna be here anymore.
- [Rillian] I look forward to the day
where I see the saints
gathered worshiping Christ
and I could cry about it.
It is gonna be so
surreal and so beautiful,
and death is just the way to get there.
- [Penny] Yeah.
(dramatic drum music)
- [Director] I fear losing
my non-believer friends and family.
(timer beeping)
(light bulbs chiming)
- [Kabal] It would be the
greatest pain to go to heaven
and not see your siblings there.
- [Rillian] I mean, my dad isn't saved
and half my family are Catholic,
and I can't imagine a more miserable place
than away from the perfect
creator of all things.
- [Calvin] In John 6, Jesus says that,
"Of all those that the
Father has given me,
I will not lose one."
And so God is faithful and just
and I trust God that He
will save all of His people.
I do pray for my loved
ones who are unbelievers.
I share the gospel with them,
but ultimately I know
it doesn't depend on me.
Salvation is in His hands.
So it's not for me to fear or worry.
- [Dmitri] In the Bible it says that
it's God's will for everyone to be saved,
but at the same time the truth is
is that not everyone will.
When I was a non-believer,
I would always wonder,
why are Christians always wanting
to shove their beliefs down my throat?
We know what the Bible says
that people will go to hell
and if we don't tell people about it,
that blood is almost on our hands.
And I do fear that there will
be people that I know and love
who won't ever come to God,
but I know that there
is still hope for them.
- [Director] We'll have
you put your masks back on.
(gentle music)